j'ai deux préoccupations majeures majeur
pourquoi parce que personne ici ne peut
accepter que le confinement et
l'enfermement subies par des enfants ou
par un conjoint ou une conjointe plus
souvent soit synonyme d'impunité face à
un père conjoint un beau père je vais
pas faire la liste violon et nous sommes
dans un paradoxe où le nombre de
plaintes déposées baissent
significativement mais évidemment nous
sommes convaincus qu'il y ait une
augmentation des violences
intrafamiliales
on a un indicateur l'indicateur revanche
je vous parle c'est celui du nombre
d'interventions à domicile de nos forces
de l'ordre gendarmerie nationale police
nationale et préfecture de police depuis
le début du confinement le 16 mars
nous sommes nous avons augmenté les
interventions à domicile alors je
précise bien ses interventions à
domicile sa première fois que j'ai donné
ce chiffre ça s'est traduit par
l'augmentation des vifs
ça n'est pas le cas c'est un indicateur
mais de 48%
c'est significatif on a aussi
l'augmentation du nombre de chat sur la
plate forme que nous avons mis en place
il ya un peu plus d'un an pour dénoncer
les violences sexuelles et sexistes
cette plateforme où on communique de
façon anonyme et puis vous avez en face
de vous un policier un gendarme selon
l'endroit où vous habitez que vous avez
indiquée qui va vous conduire vers le
dépôt de plainte mais au départ c'est
anonyme donc c'est plus facile
là on a une augmentation très
significative c'était multiplié par 14
alors ça ne veut pas dire là aussi qu'
on a abouti à chaque fois à 14 fois plus
de plaintes ou de prêts plainte en ligne
parce que les gens étant chez eux vont
aussi plus facilement sur ce chat là
mais c'est quand même un indicateur de
problèmes que nous connaissons et je
pouffe données chiffrées en 2019 on a eu
54 échanges en moyenne pour des
violences intrafamiliales en 2001 jeu
nous sommes à 759 chat relatifs à cela
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un problème
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
mes collègues du gouvernement
on s'est mobilisé pour faire en sorte
que tous les moyens d'appeler au secours
soit possible parce que c'est plus
difficile d'appeler le 17 si le conjoint
violent est à côté de vous évidemment
c'est plus difficile d'aller au
commissariat si le conjoint est toujours
avec vous et donc on a essayé de faire
en sorte que nous puissions de façon
dématérialisée sur la plateforme que je
viens d'évoquer
j'ai mobilisé s'était d'ailleurs je vais
citer à l'époque je le cite volontiers
un échange que j'ai vu avec laurent
wauquiez président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes
j'ai mobilisé le 114 le 114 numéro de
téléphone qui était dédiée aux personnes
malentendantes
mais qui nous a permis en fait par texto
de donner l'alerté en se disant sin
personal téléphone ne peut pas
téléphoner appelé le 17 ou le 39 19 pour
se faire accompagner
elle peut si elle va aux toilettes en
cachette envoyé un texto d'urgence nous
traitons 170 appels enfin textos par
jour grâce au 114
j'ai mis en place ce dispositif il
montre son efficacité
je n'ai pas les chiffres sur le nombre
de personnes interpellées dans ce cadre
là mais nous les aurons et je vous les
communiquerons volontiers nous avons
élargi oc dans des lieux différents vous
avez évoqué les pharmacies que j'avais
négocié avec la présidente de l'ordre
des pharmaciens sur un modèle espagnol
cette initiative des associations
espagnoles j'en avais eu connaissance et
j'ai appelé la présidente de l'ordre
pour lui proposer ça et les pharmaciens
ont tout de suite joué le jeu je sais au
moment où je vous parle j'ai au moins
quatre personnes interpellées dans le
cadre d'un signalement
on va dire pharmacie marlène schiappa à
développer aussi des présences des
permanences dans quelques centres
commerciaux sur lequel on a là des gens
qui vous accompagne et qui peuvent vous
aider à donner l'alerté
aussi on a essayé du coup d'avoir tous
ces dispositifs une plateforme de
logements sans compter les moyens donnés
aux associations mais aussi à la
possibilité d'accueillir les d'ouvrir le
financement de 20 mille nuitées
financées dans le cadre du budget de
marlène schiappa pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse accueillir des femmes ou
des hommes violents
et voilà et je peux vous dire que j'ai
donné des instructions très claires au
préfet c'est que je ne veux pas entendre
parler de problèmes matériels si jamais
on a besoin des bergers qui que ce soit
en urgence aujourd'hui nous
réquisitionnons des hôtels chaque fois
que c'est nécessaire pour loger des gens
qui sont dans la rue et pas question
qu'un préfet puisse me dire ah non mais
on n'avait pas la bonne ligne budgétaire
je pense que le message a vraiment était
passé pour que nous puissions sur ce
dispositif être totalement totalement
engagée ce ne sont que quelques exemples
mais je peux vous dire ce que nous avons
voulu j'ai même poussé
aussi où j'ai accompagné parce que je
veux pas revendiquer cela une
proposition qui avait été faite par le
dggn élargi au dgpn
les appels d'initiative c'est à dire que
nous connaissons certaines familles ul
détention mais il n'y a pas eu de dépôt
de plainte il ya peu une sanction
judiciaire
mais il ya peut-être un risque j'ai
demandé à nos forces de faire des appels
d'initiative de téléphoner et
d'apprécier la situation
jean pierre sueur même interrogé sur la
capacité d'un policier a apprécié une
situation mais là quand ils appellent
ils sont au son de la voix qui est un
problème
nous avons interpellé plusieurs
conjoints violents dans ce cadre là donc
on essaye vraiment de faire en sorte que
tous les dispositifs puissent être
utilisés parce qu'on sait que
l'enfermement c'est un risque de
violence et que s'il ya risque de
violences il faut évidemment que nous
puissions agir très vite tout jour j'ai
pas finir mais c'est alors si vous
acceptez masculinisation ses plus vives
sur les pharmacies centres commerciaux
ce qui serait pas intéressant que les
préfets la liste des pharmacies
concernées par une par département tout
parce que nous on n'arrive pas à
résoudre dans le département je connais
bien on n'arrive pas à voir cette
lisibilité là parce que ça permet aussi
de faire des relais les maires ils
peuvent faire des relais enfin voila je
pense que c'est très important de
relayer cette information parce que vous
vous dites tout mais est-ce que tout me
font vraiment est ce que toutes ont la
capacité de faire parce que c'est pas si
simple c'est important des lieux des
coutumes et donc du coup est ce que vous
nous dites toutes les pharmacies de fond
ou est ce qu'il y à du volontariat j'ai
envie de dire ce que c'est ça la
lisibilité est ce qu'on peut dire aux
femmes toutes les pharmacies sont censés
vous écoutez en cas de problème
bon voilà je vais inversée votre
question je n'imagine pas un pharmacien
en france qui est sollicité par une
femme et qui lui dit s'il vous plaît
aidez-moi appelé police secours qu'il ne
le fasse pas et quand j'ai travaillé sur
cette idée avec la présidente de l'ordre
des pharmaciens
on s'est pas posé cette question là
parce qu'elle savait que personne ne
seraient dans cette situation là il
s'agit pas de dire on va protéger
physiquement etc
il s'agit juste en espagne il ya même eu
un code c'est la personne venait disait
je veux un masque 19 à ce moment là le
pharmacien prend le nom laisse partir à
la personne et à
appelle la police pour dire j'ai une
alerte il ya madame untel qui habite à
temps l'endroit j'ai leur donnant ce qui
m'a demandé masque 19 ça n'existe pas et
donc ces voix là mais évidemment je n'ai
pas fait la publicité sur masque 19 pour
que sinon ça perdait tous sens
c'étaient les associant qui avait fait
cela voilà je je pense que ce n'est pas
à 100% efficace
hélas mais c'est vraiment l'idée de dire
on s'offrent tous les moyens possibles
le 114 est un dispositif qui ne pourra
pas durer sous la forme du 114 parce que
c'est le centre hospitalier
universitaire de grenoble qu'ils gèrent
ils n'ont pas la possibilité dans la
durée de le faire ils ont accepté de le
faire mais j'ai demandé à nos services
de faire en sorte que ces dispositifs
soient pérennisés ensuite et que la
plateforme que nous avons contre les
violences puissent demain traités par
chat mais puissent aussi traiter les
textos voilà mes jeux de questions et je
n'aurai pas la prétention de vous dire
le problème est réglé je crains hélas
qu'il ne soit pas réglé et je peux
parler des appels pour les violences
faites au mieux vos enfants mais elles
sont nombreuses aussi ces violences là
et c'est un sujet sur lequel nous sommes
mobilisés mais les consignes ont été
données d'être plus vigilants en cas je
vais conclure ma réponse sur ce sujet en
vous rappelant que chaque jour en france
or confinement ce sont 200 femmes qui
sont accompagnés par les services de
police est gendarme à 200 alors je sais
qu' il peut y avoir une polémique parce
qu'on peut y avoir un trou dans la
raquette et peut y avoir une erreur
d'appréciation et peut y avoir une
mauvaise gestion
ce que je n'aime pas c'est qu'on mette
en cause du coup tout le système
policier où tout le système des
gendarmes quand je sais que chaque jour
200 femmes sont accompagnées dans ce
cadre là et combien sont sauvés par dial
je ne sais pas mais c'est quand même
assez significatif